هذه ليست الحرب الوحيده في اوكرانيا خلف
هذه النيران تدور حرب اخرى غير تقليديه
تصل عمق الاراضي الروسيه والاوكرانيه
والحلفاء ايضا جهاز الامن الفيدرالي
الروسي
وامريكا بشن هجمات واسعه النطاق من
الاراضي الاوكرانيه عبر استخدام البنيه
التحتيه للشبكه الاوكرانيه امر مكنها من
استخدام انواع جديده من الاسلحه الصبرانيه
وبشكل سري اذا استهدفت الهجمات البنى
التحتيه الحيويه الروسيه
بالمقابل تتهم واشنطن موسكو بشن هجمات
سيبرانيه واختراق كاميرات امنيه اوكرانيه
خاصه لجمع معلومات استخباراتيه حول عبور
قوافل الامدادات العسكريه الحكومه الروسيه
وقراصنه مدعومون حكوميا يواصلون تنفيذ
هجمات ضد انظمه تكنولوجيا معلومات
اوكرانيه في اطار غزو الروسي الاوكرانيا
وفقا لجهاز الامن الفيدرالي الروسي واشنطن
تقدم اوكرانيا على انها وراء الهجمات
السيبرانيه من خلال مجموعه اي تي اي
الى جانب تطوير هجمات بمشاركه بالتعاون مع
مجموعات انونموس العالميه وجست كلين
الامريكيه و جي ان جي الجورجيه اضافه
لمجموعات في تركيا وبولندا
وبينما تتجمد جبهات القتال على الاراضي
الاوكرانيه بانتظار هجوم الربيع تبدو
الحرب اكثر حراره بين المتحاربين
الصبرانيه حرب وان كانت في الخفاء لكنها
تقض مضاجع الكبار وبلا نهر
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات